hello
[Applause]
oh my gosh i'm so good i'm very excited
to be here i'm so star struck you are
just our favorite in our home we sing to
all your songs i mean
oh my in the hell to my skin is tingling
yeah oh my gosh i'm sitting over here
really really shocked i cannot believe
you just
said that you're star struck thank you
so much it's so true
i actually made it a huge point i was
like do you think china
would come on the show because i'm such
a big fan of hers
and then you said yes and i'm so excited
because i'm just going to be on the cool
list with my kids because of it
and um now qb halloween is actually not
your first time working with adam
sandler
yes no it's not um i did grown-ups one
and grown-ups too with him
and i tell you well you already know
he's absolutely incredible
i love him i love being on his sets he
always has his family around and it's
just a very
comfortable environment you know what
i'm saying i love it every time i get to
work with him
the first time back to work i had just
had all of she was only six months
old we went to africa to make this film
called blended
and the only reason i felt comfortable
doing it because it felt so intimidating
was because it was with adam and he's
such a family man
and i just i knew what i was getting
into he's my cinematic soul mate and yes
you're right he
creates a warm safe loving family
oriented
full of laughs environment exactly and
super loyal as well like if you work
with him once
and he likes you and your vibes match i
mean
you'll probably have a job for life with
him he's super loyal
you're absolutely right and in fact he
had happy madison and i was starting
flower films with my partner nan
and we became really close on the
wedding singer and we would travel and
take holidays and like hang out
and then we produced 50 first dates
together
and then we made blended and i
understand that you're starting a
production company
yes i am very early stages of it but
when i tell you i'm so excited i mean
it's it's cool
working for other people and getting to
tell other stories but
there are a lot of stories that i have
inside of me as well i've been doing
this since i was five and
i have a lot of ideas and i'm i'm ready
to take a
new venture so i'm very excited very
excited well i have to say
i mean you know you look at a reese
witherspoon and
you know when we were making flower
films back you know when i was 19
and i would see sandra bullock she had
fortis films and
you know there were a lot of people who
have taken on
sort of being um in charge of their
destiny
as well as creating these wonderful
other jobs for people and telling
stories
that they feel may not be are that or
may not be being told or
how about this like part of why
charlie's angels came out was because i
wanted to see girls doing
action that would also love each other
and be funny and i didn't see that being
made out there so
do you have like a first thing or what
was like
oh gosh if you could have any dream what
would be your first project
oh my gosh my first project
well i'm actually i'm doing action right
now on black lightning
so at this point i really just want
a great story something that feels
genuine and also after this year i think
people are ready for something that's
going to challenge them a little bit
emotionally
and mentally and those are the things
that i want to do at this point that's
my dream project
i love you being in charge of this
because you've
grown up you're wise the way you're
speaking who you are as a person
also you have such a big following that
i mean i i just anything i can ever
do please call on me count on me like
i you know i think starting a company is
so empowering and i think you're going
to be
amazing at it and yes adam is a very
loyal person his company is still all
the same people for 25 almost 30 years
so you know just insane
it's insane i went back there and was
seeing people that i had seen when i was
10
working on it was like it's a family
well the producer that i learned from
her name was linda opts
and we were making this film called bad
girls and i saw her running around and
solving all the problems and i thought
that's who i want to be i want to be a
problem solver and she used to have a
term called pc
permanent crew you find the people that
you love and you stick with them and i'm
here with chris miller and ember
truesdale
who i call ember trueheart and our nancy
javona and we've been together for 25
years
and they are my permanent crew and i am
theirs and so you find your tribe and
you stick together
and you make your dreams come true
because when you're alone you're just a
kid with dreams sort of sitting on them
like little nest eggs
and then you meet other people and the
eggs start to crack so when you find the
people that are like-minded and
have the similar dreams or even a
different skill set than you because it
takes so many different types of skill
sets
to get it done then you will start to
build the flames and embers will ignite
and you'll be off to the races thank you
for that advice i'm learning something i
learned something from adam working with
him
i'm learning something from you right
now i'm taking all of this into my
production company
i want to surround myself with people
that i trust and
there are a lot of things that i don't
know i want to learn you know what i'm
saying i want to learn
and yet there's so much experience that
you have already and i tried to bring
that to flower films when i was 19 i had
been working in films
my whole life as you have been it was a
great asset so you're already off to the
most amazing start
china and mclean i am the biggest fan
and i'm so honored to be speaking with
you and please know on behalf of me and
my daughters olive and frankie
that we will be singing your songs
tonight cheering and watching
this show back and freaking out that i'm
talking to you thank you so much
[Music]
you